et Monsieur Sifaoui comme vous le voyez
je vous ai laissé un certain temps je
vous remercie monsieur le Président
d'intervention et et si je vais vous
accusez d'être dans un copinage et si je
l'ai fait c'est surtout parce que
jusqu'à présent vous n'aviez pas eu
l'occasion de vous exprimer publiquement
sur des sujets ou effectivement vous
avez été mise en cause dès le départ si
je puis dire
je voudrais tout de même avant de passer
à
ce qui relie aujourd'hui c'est à dire
cet homme de question précise je
voudrais vous dire et qui a quelques
propos
qui ne peuvent pas fonctionner
l'un de ses propos
ne doit pas se traiter ici il a
l'intérêt d'être
du public comment et sur votre ressenti
concernant les propos donne de nos
collègues de cette de cette mission
parce que les choses peuvent se traiter
autrement
vous avez parlé
de l'utiliser le mot on s'attaque
faudrait être bien au clair sur un point
c'est que cette commission d'enquête de
s'attaque à personne
voilà elle ne s'attaque pas à un
ministre encore au moins un gouvernement
elle établit les faits
elle pose des questions elle écoute les
réponses elle en tire des conclusions
tout ça ne pas s'attaquer
bien entendu je ne crois pas que vous
ayez pu entendre qui que ce soit parler
de détournement d'argent pour madame la
ministre
de copinage de manière générale sauf une
citation que vous avez faite
c'est pas notre notre sujet ici
la même façon on sait pas attaqué au
préfet de Ravel
en rien
moi je respecte apporteur tous les
membres cette commission respectent les
préfets de la République
on a simplement posé des questions
sur des points de procédure
des méthodes administratives des façons
de faire
et des résultats
on est dans notre rôle
et en faisant ça ça n'enlève rien aux
qualités propres de la personne
nous avons toujours considéré qu'il peut
y avoir dans une vie de qualité de
chacun d'entre nous d'ailleurs des
moments où il peut y avoir des erreurs
ils sont commises voilà on a même fait
nous un texte de loi sur cela la prise
en compte
pardon du droit à l'erreur
elle était loin mais voilà
et il peut y avoir un moment ou un autre
d'une carrière des difficultés
particulières nous les avons pointés
nous les pointerons dans notre rapport
et c'est tout c'est notre rôle c'est
ensuite l'administration de diaskala à
dire c'était le rapport de l'Inspection
générale de l'administration des prix de
décision personnelle qui ne relève pas
de nous mais en aucune façon vous
pourrez prendre le script exact de tout
ce que nous avons dit à n'a aucune façon
nous ne sommes dans un système d'attaque
de qui que ce soit
et vous le verrez d'ailleurs dans votre
dans notre audition nous nous
attaquerons pas à vous non plus nous
demanderons à établir des faits
questionnerons
et vous nous répondrez aussi précisément
que vous le voudrez
[Musique]